bonjour bienvenue au marché couvert de
sens pour le troisième débat des
élections municipales en direct sur
france 3 bourgogne nos invités nous
attendent sur le plateau il est temps
d'aller les rejoindre
nous continuons donc notre série de
débats dans les grandes villes de
bourgogne après nevers et mâcon nous
sommes donc à sens dans ce très beau
décor du marché couvert en partenariat
avec l'yonne républicaine en lice dans
cette élection et sur notre plateau le
maire sortant michel fourré divers
gauche bonjour jour chez nous pour l'ump
élus des lycées charles hervé moreau qui
représente la tête de liste marie louise
fort absente ce week-end bonjour à vous
bonjour pascal simon mène la liste ps
bonjour bonjour pascal simon edouard
ferrand un candidat du front national
dans cette élection bonjour bonjour
edouard ferrand et francine weecksteen
mène une liste sans étiquette bonjour
bienvenue sont aussi candidates dans
cette élection municipale de sens claude
vivier soutenu par le modem et marie
noëlle lehodey pour le front de gauche
merci donc à tous les cinq d'avoir
accepté notre invitation chez vous
devant votre télé vous pouvez réagir à
ce débat vos réactions passeront à
l'antenne sur notre site internet et sur
le réseau twitter avec le hashtag lvl
bourgogne et f3 bourgogne nous allons
aborder avec pascal de sousse à 1 à
consoeur de l'yonne républicaine un
certain nombre de points précis de la
vie de sens mais d'abord il va falloir
pour commencer que vous nous expliquer
ce qui s'est passé dans la vie politique
que certains qualifient de plus multi
use de cette ville pendant ce mandat
100 c'est la seule ville où le maire de
2014 n'est pas celui de 2008 michel
fourré vous êtes le maire de 2014 il
sait pas s'il vous plaît monsieur petite
question au préalable son importance
pourquoi est ce que mon iphone n'est pas
présente dans ce débat propose qu'on
c'est une question que je vais poser à
charles cher monsieur veulent s il vous
plaît énormément à intervenir parce que
vous allez intervenir vous allez
intervenir d'hui marée du soir vous
allez à l'opposition de 2008 jusqu'en
l'amour elle a refusé un débat la
semaine dernière elle refuse aujourd'hui
de venir débattre je pense que c'est un
déni de démocratie que c'est très grave
et j'attire l'attention de ces données
que ils veulent se faire diriger par une
femme qui est toujours absente est ce
que vous savez ce qu'elle aime un homme
fort je ne sais pas mais on va les voir
chez vous le dire parce que vous le
savez pas malin fors et danses trad
inauguré un lavoir à 20 kilomètres d'ici
voila voila ce déni de démocratie je
trouve que c'est une autre c'est une
autre comme le personnel politique
d'ouverture à gauche de métier va prend
pas avec les raids entend bien pareil
moi de voir ces polémiques je sors mon
carton rouge je sauve au carton rouge
contre madame fort justement 4 cartons
rouges contre ces élus municipaux qui
aujourd'hui font un déni de démocratie
ont été incapables de relever les
finances de la ville au contraire qu'ils
ont tiré avant par les humains avant par
les edouard ferrand 7,7 une intervention
effectivement sur notre sujet politique
qui fait partie des questions je voulais
vous poser on va juste sur soi un tout
petit peu je propose ce soir la même
route qui réponde à ça et puis on
passera à vous ensuite oui je pense
qu'il faudrait reprendre un petit peu de
mesure qu'on les débats rappelons pour
ceux qui nous regardent que marie louise
fort a été maire de sens qu'elle a été
battu en 2008
par la terminer ce mandat en étant
effectivement adjoint aux finances donc
contrairement ce que vient de dire mon
voisin mais je pense qu'on va voir des
échanges qui vont être peut-être un peu
musclé mais contrairement à ce que vient
dire monsieur s'il vous plaît edouard
ferrand l'est répondu oui mais s'il vous
plaît vous accepter des règles devraient
accepter les règles du débat s'il vous
plaît vous laisser répondre sur les
raisons quand je dirais contrairement à
ce que vient de dire monsieur monsieur
ferrand en fait madame fort n'est pas
dans le département et à la prévenue
largement lorsque vous l'avez invités
largement en amont qu'en fait elle ne
serait pas là ce week-end là donc moi je
vais lui répondre pourquoi je suis là
effectivement je suis là d'abord parce
que j'ai mené l'opposition municipale
pendant
six ans donc à ce titre à ce titre
est ce qu'on peut parler avec ce
monsieur
on va essayer donc j'ai mené la position
municipale pendant six ans donc il était
tout à fait naturel que je sois 7 à 7
places et ensuite je suis en deuxième
place sur la sur la liste et on n'a pas
voulu mener là je dirais la une
politique d'absence dans ce débat qui je
l'espère mais malheureusement avec ce
que j'entends peut-être sera très
intéressant on n'a pas voulu mener
l'absence sur ce débat est donc c'est
pour cette raison que je suis présent de
façon complètement naturel je le répète
en tant que responsable l'opposition
refusé de siéger aujourd'hui les
sénonais doivent ouvrir les yeux on ne
veut pas faire confiance à des gens qui
ont rejeté les peaux jeu est différent
juste un mot que je vous permets de vous
rappeler que nous gérons les temps de
parole dans cette émission pour tout le
monde est à temps de parole équitable
non parce que je me permets d'y intégrer
les goulamas des médiations je me
permets de vous mentir aujourd'hui vous
êtes en train de prendre des normes
allemandes avance michel fourré s'il
vous plaît c'est à vous qui avait été
posée la première question est bien ça
commence plutôt mal j'ai l'impression
que monsieur ferrand bien pas bientôt
s'arrêter parce qu'il aura plus de temps
de parole et ça a été extrêmement
compliqué alors oui expliquez nous
pourquoi vous êtes le maire de sens
alors qu'un autre mère avait été vu et
bien monsieur pâris donc à démissionner
il faut bien le dire
il a perdu sa majorité on peut le dire
comme ça ben non parce que quand il a
démissionné il avait encore une majorité
c'est là qu'est le problème c'est qu'il
est parti
d'un seul coup il nous a plus ou moins
j'allais dire laisser tomber et donc
j'ai été obligé de revendre abandonné
sommaire moi j'ai aucune affinité
et on est en train de faire éditer et
monter des magouilles dans cette ville
aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
non c'est très bien c'est fait on laisse
dernier daniel parisse a démissionné
j'ai donc pris sa place
je dois dire que j'ai pris sa place mais
ça a été extrêmement compliqué parce que
quand je suis arrivée dans le bureau du
maire il n'y avait plus rien plus de
dossiers plus rien du tout et j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à travailler
correctement au démarrage reprendre tous
les dossiers ça m'a pris vraiment et
c'est cissé d'un des affiches et un
maire à temps plein c'est à dire j'ai
essayé de remonter la ville on va y
venir sur les dossiers bien sûr de soi
de ses 131 500 c'est à vous que je pose
la question suivante vous faisiez partie
de l'équipe de daniel parisse vous ai vu
tiqué quand michel fourré a dit nous a
abandonnés il n'a pas abandonné pour moi
la seule réponse c'est la division est
effectivement là quand on entend les
premiers propos de cette émission c'est
vraiment la division qui pour moi n'a
jamais permis de mobiliser toutes les
énergies qui n'a personne n'a jamais
permis non plus de permettre la victoire
contre les grands défis que nous avons
chacun à surmonter dans notre vie privée
mais aussi bien sûr dans notre vie
publique quand nous nous engageons que
ce soit dans la vie associative ou dans
la vie politique ces grands défis nous
nous devons les sur les surmonter les
gagner une victoire contre eux et puis
évidemment à 100 ça a été comme cela
comme dans d'autres situations et nous
avons très rapidement et est confronté à
ce qu'on peut appeler à un syndrome que
que l'on a vécu un petit peu ce tout à
l'heure c'est j'ai raison ils ont tort
eh bien je pense que cela aboutit
forcément à des clivages à des clivages
idéologiques à des clivages partisans
qui empêche de travailler ensemble et
donc empêche de travailler surtout pour
cent c'est les sénonais et bien sûr cela
aboutit à la dea la démission du maire
parce que la situation n'était plus
possible à gérer et bien sûr pour un
maire c'est extrêmement difficile de
démissionner parce que un maire c'est
quelqu'un qui s'engage c'est un maire
qui a mère est quelqu'un qui a une
vision pour sa ville qui veut construire
qui veut répondre aux besoins des
habitants et évidemment pour un maire
c'est extrêmement difficile de
démissionner parce que sinon vous êtes
finalement un petit peu tranquille dans
ce débat vous puisque vous n'étiez pas
dans l'équipe municipale en revanche le
parti socialiste était candidat aux
élections municipales à sens on va dire
que contre aussi le daniel paris ce donc
qui d'ailleurs vous accusez pendant son
mandat de l'avoir bûcheronner absolument
il nous a accusés d'avoir bûcheronner à
tort puisque nous on a été les allées
des observateurs de la vie politique
senez et on a été des observateurs au
départ on a eu un soutien on revient un
soutien critique on est passé dans la
franche opposition aux premiers
renoncements entre autres sur les sur le
las la poursuite de certains dossiers
qui avaient été démarrée par madame fort
alors on va pas parler des absents je
pense que monsieur moore on le connaît
assez bien il fera suivre mais tout des
marins ce qui nous est arrivé cet été ça
a démarré en 2008 ça a démarré en 2008
il était urgent à l'époque il est urgent
d'arrêter d'arrêter ce que la mandature
fort avait mis en place on a été on a
été plusieurs à se présenter nous avec
une association qui représente la gauche
à 100 c'est une gauche rassemblée avec
deux partis politiques majeurs on était
déjà ensemble la dernière fois daniel
parisse nous a grillé la politesse il a
monté une équipe avec de très bonnes
intentions qui était de refaire passer
une politique progressiste pour sens et
de sortir madame fort de la mairie
la composition même de son équipe fait
qu'on est aboutie on a abouti à ce qui
s'est passé cet été mais voilà nous on a
observé on est toujours là on a toujours
le même programme et on a toujours le
même combat éviter que la droite
revienne en ville et surtout que
l'extrême droite ne fasse un score qui
serait monsieur ferrand une honte pour
notre ville alors bien vous avez prendre
voir quand même dire un petit mot
monsieur à barbe sur le chapitre suivant
parce que l'on avait déjà déclaré il
fait l'école avec les rides
téléspecteurs mais c'est fait c'est fait
lui cette fin ils ont vu c'est
finalement je vais aujourd'hui j'étais
d'enchaîner sur le mot programme qu'a
prononcé pascal simon non on va avancer
sur le programme edouard ferrand et vous
allez pouvoir exécuter mes trucs avant
de rentrer effectivement dans le détail
d'un certain nombre de points précis un
mot de chacun je vous dise
s'il vous plaît ou alors je vous donne
on y crée vous êtes au centre même de la
division à 108 marion l'aérien conserver
ou vague sur ce marché couvert par les
différents ne jugez pas débat et avait
affronté ou au tout ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il est temps il est
temps de sortir les sortants la ville de
sens c'est une ville aujourd'hui qui a
besoin de retrouver de l'air dues
souvent le mime on y vient donner vous
allez nous expliquer avec les arguments
mais s'il vous plaît que sur les 4
dernières mandatures on a eu quatre
couleurs faire un type différent ça
serve sérieusement vous connaissez les
règles d'un jeu aussi bien dans le bon
sens osez bon sens mais envoie le bon à
partir de maintenant est sifflé ses
brunchs les autres ferrand s'il vous
plaît je vous annonce que quatre sujets
suivants vous n'aurez plus de temps de
parole parce qu'on va pas pouvoir
consciencieux le laisser terminer le non
monsieur il est temps de parler du
programme en bourse il ajouté les
absents là moi j'ai voulu simplement
avertir parce que je suis aux citoyens
que ce serait possible qu'on fait on est
fier sous les 2 ou d'hommes politiques
mois de journalistes mais s'il vous
plaît ne mélangez pas les genres en
donnant votre avis sur la façon dont je
gère je gère ce débat s'il vous plaît
une phrase une foule ans après s'il vous
plaît terminer ma trace il faut arrêter
non il faut arrêter parce qu'on va y
arriver le mot dire non je veux
simplement dire que aujourd'hui à 6 ans
l'essai de genève le autre chose on
applique du tyran si les sénonais
veulent autre chose ils vous le diront
ils vous diront 23 edouard ferrand on a
compris je propose qu'on avance s'il
vous plaît parce que sinon on va pas y
arriver
l'intérêt de ce débat c'est tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer je pense que
vous l'avez fait donc moi j'avais envie
que vous nous parler de votre vie on la
ville de sens qui est une ville
particulière en bourgogne on sait
qu'elle est à l'extrême nord de la
région on dit souvent qu'elle est au
confluent de plusieurs régions il
finalement elle a des difficultés
d'identité la jeune chambre économique a
rendu un livre blanc à 100 ce titre et
je crois vous me direz si je me trompe
ville endormie ou ville d'avenir moi
j'ai envie que ce soit vous michel
fourie qui vous nous donniez d'abord
votre vision de cette ville de sens
qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce qu'il va pas
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire on va dire à
grands traits à votre avis
oui ville endormie c'est c'est vrai il
suffit d'aller à
19 heures dans les rues pour voir que
tout est un peu fermé il n'y a pas
tellement de vie nocturne c'est vrai que
c'est une ville qui s'est surtout
repliée sur elle même
la cause est vraisemblablement que une
partie des habitants de sens ont un peu
déserté la commune ceux qui ont un
métier qui ont qui peuvent payer des
impôts à 100 son parti dans les villages
alentour s'installer pour avoir une
diminution de la pression fiscale et on
se retrouve maintenant à sens avec des
gens qui sont pas loin de la précarité
c'est à dire je parle du ghetto de la
zup et les petits grande de la région
qui est une des plus grandes de la
région c'est vrai et qui donc
commence à être dans des difficultés
économiques importantes
on a quand même des atouts il faut bien
le dire on est près de l'île de france
si je reparle de la zup il faut dire
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
descendent de l'île de france pour
s'installer à sens malheureusement ils
ont souvent que le rsa et il améliore
pas
la qualité fiscales de la ville
et la hacker qui approcheront message
oui oui mais le problème c'est ça
parlait du peuple comme ça écoutez
écoutez volare monsieur ferrand vous à
rêver mais vous allez vous exprimer à
votre tour bon
ça c'est possible on peut
discuter jeudi je dois dire que nous
avons des gros problèmes au niveau de
rentrées fiscales et il est important
que nous arrivions à faire revenir des
ménages des salariés dans notre ville
pour essayer de compenser ces pertes ont
fait comment il faut faire venir des
entreprises mais il faut bien dire aussi
que toutes les villes de france et de
navarre veulent faire venir des
entreprises oui et je crois que c'est
assez difficile de raconter français
avec steve on voulait réagir oui alors
pour moi je ne partage pas du tout
l'avis de michel bize je trouve que sans
c'est une extraordinaire ville avec un
potentiel énorme à vous rappeliez sa
situation géographique c'est vrai
qu'elle est à la confluence de trois
régions importantes l'île de france la
région centre et la région bourgogne et
c'est effectivement pour % c'est un
atout énorme elle a surtout un autre
atout important ce sont ses habitants
là les habitants sont investis dans leur
ville il y à un monde associatif qui est
très riche un monde économique aussi qui
est très diversifiée et qui est un monde
commercial qui permet de répondre aux
attentes des habitants je pense que c'en
est une ville d'avenir et je crois qu'il
faut faire confiance aux acteurs qui
sont sur ce territoire parce qu'ils ont
envie que sens devienne un pôle
attractif pour le futur pascal simon oui
je pense que les atouts de sens
il vaudrait mieux parler de potentiel
c'est le potentiel de sens c'est son
patrimoine historique touristique
culturelle c'est aussi sa proximité avec
l'ile-de-france à une situation
géographique qui est tout de même qui
est tout de même extrêmement
avantageuses c'est ce potentiel il n'a
pas été développé pendant les douze
dernières années suffisamment il ya eu
des essais il ya eu des bonnes il ya eu
des bonnes idées qui n'ont pas été
emmené au bout ya eu beaucoup de
renoncement on a besoin de partenariats
et il faut qu'on puisse nous à l'échelle
de sang se le dire on a besoin de
partenariat intercommunal existants et
aussi de partenariat créé je pense à
l'arrivée d'une ou du numérique du très
haut débit il est impératif et urgent
qu'on créé un syndicat mixte numérique
pour pouvoir accompagner et accélérer
l'arrivée du très haut débit sur sens
c'est ça que les entreprises attendent
l'offre foncière madame fort a détruit
des projets qu'on avait un qu'on avait
avant 2002 entre autres d'un
établissement public foncier sur lequel
elle était d'accord et puis ensuite
qu'elle a tué dans l'oeuf lorsqu'elle
est arrivée aux affaires nous avons
besoin d'un établissement public foncier
pour pouvoir attirer les entreprises
mais ya pas que ça il n'y a pas que ça
il faut qu'on puisse rééquilibrer les
effectifs scolaires qu'on accueille
qu'on améliore l'accueil de la petite
enfance il faut qu'on ait plus de
restaurant scolaire pour que les enfants
soient accueillis il faut qu'au niveau
du logement puisse avoir une offre qui
soit meilleur qu'on reprenne la
gouvernance qui a été perdue auprès des
bailleurs sociaux il ya énormément de
choses à faire pour valoriser nos atouts
et faire en sorte que ce sens redevienne
la ville attractive qu'elle aurait
jamais dû cesser d'être valorisons nos
potentiels charles hervé moreau moi je
note pascal simon a dit les 12 dernières
années ça veut dire qu'il englobait
finalement les deux équipes municipales
successives donc vous avez à répondre là
dessus sur le fait que le potentiel de
la ville soit pas de son point de vue
développé je mets
dray d'ailleurs je vous remercie de
redonner la parole parce que j'ai
l'impression que je ne les ai pas eus
depuis depuis quelques temps donc j'ai
quand même répondre à monsieur simon en
ce qui concerne les effets de la
mandature puisque il dit on a tout
arrêté dans les effets de la mandature
en fait on a on a continu des grands
projets qui sont les par exemple les
projets de l'âne rue où les projets du
hall de sports qui étaient en fait des
projets de marie louise fort si on
regarde aussi au point de vue d'un
avantage qui n'a pas été qui n'a pas été
cité au niveau de sens ce son territoire
c'est le port de gros et le port de gron
a été quand même initiée également par
par madame fort donc aussi pour
commenter un petit peu ce qui a été dit
voilà bien ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure c'est c'est vrai que l'essai
d'année à mon avis ne comprennent plus
rien de ce qui se passe dans cette ville
et on a certainement assez mais il faut
rappeler quand même que si monsieur
monsieur pâris a démissionné c'est parce
que en fait son budget n'a pas été voté
et c'est extrêmement rare dans une
municipalité qu'un budget ne soit pas
votée les capacités financières de la
ville
qu'est ce qu'on a fait en 2013 en fait
pendant une année on a géré et donc sans
vouloir attaquer directement le maire
actuel on a on n'a rien fait depuis ce
qui depuis c'est la nouvelle élection
nous avons perdu on l'a alors c'est vrai
que c'est bénéfique parce qu'on le voit
dire que vous allez ça va être votre
j'ai l'impression d'être au coin non non
non vous avez alors ce que je suis
intervenu pour remettre le débat en
place s'il vous plaît venez nombreux
vous avez une minute de temps de parole
de plus que tous les os pour l'instant
on voulait c'est terminé vous auriez dû
monsieur ouellet précisé qu un fort n'a
pas voulu débattre ça a été fait vous
l'avez pas vous laisser terminer charles
v m euros ça va bouger je n'ai encore
rien dit vous avez parlé plus je vais
vous laisser parler nous laisser faire
une année quand je suis pas négocié
différentes
l'intérim s'il vous plaît edouard
ferrand alors sinon je serais bien guy
miclo arrêtez s'il vous plaît je voulais
répondent aussi à monsieur si monsieur
simon ce qui concerne cette espèce cet
établissement public
donc des villes dont la plupart des
villes sont dotés il faut le dire oui
mais je ne vais pas je vais pas revenir
sur la situation financière parce qu'il
va il va monter sûr c'est peut-être sur
ses grands chevaux mais si on revient
sur la situation financière que nous
avons eues en 2001 qui a été tout de
suite c'est du passé c'est toléré ce nom
ce n'est pas en les deux programmes
ce n'est pas je n'irai ce n'est pas du
passé je hais ce que vous me laissez
répondre monsieur simon et qu'à partir
du moment effectivement on est dans une
situation financière difficile la
première des choses c'est de remettre la
ville dans un dans un sens de bonne
gestion dans un sens de bonne
gouvernance et dans un sens d' équilibre
financier c'est ce que nous avons fait
je me rappelle que c'est en 2005 que le
premier budget de la ville a pu être
équilibré donc je pense qu'il faut
redonner des vérités lallaing exactement
où elle où elles sont édouard ferrand
qu'est ce que vous voudriez pour cette
ville avançons après la pala partis
politiques parlons de la vie n'en
simplement moi je voudrais dire que je
suis un homme d'expérience j'ai siégé
sept ans au conseil municipal ça fait 16
ans que je suis élue régionale et que je
m'occupe notamment des problèmes de sens
donc on vous dit anglais
ceux ci voulaient vous me laissez deux
minutes pour vous répondre parce que
sinon on va pas y arriver simplement moi
ce que tu as vous dire très clairement
où bella pas masquer ces jo qui sont
présents sur ce plateau le meilleur
conseil que je pourrais leur donner
c'est de retourner à l'école parce que
côté c'est pas leur fort aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que la ville
de sens à trois gros problème
les finances publiques 2 le commerce 3
le communautarisme sur les finances
publiques entre 2000 et 2011 soit sous
la gestion de gauche comme sur la
gestion de droite la dette enfin les
impôts augmenté à sens de plus 65 % on a
une dette par habitant aujourd'hui qui
est de 781 euros par habitant c'est
énorme et moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut bien dressés contrairement à ce
qu'a fait le maire précédent faut
baisser les indemnités du maire il faut
baisser les habilités à toi il faudrait
des sites positif deuxième gros problème
de la ville de sens son commerce
aujourd'hui alors qu'une division sous
le marché couvert alors qu'une division
également au conseil municipal le les
commerçants également c# et c'est pas
normal parce qu'il ya un vrai potentiel
ici à 300 commerçants g de notre
émission vous êtes en train de dérouler
leur verser dans homère 550 sont fermés
à cause de faillite on est largement
au-dessus de la moyenne des vidéastes
imola et simplement pourquoi je crois
que mon terminée il ya eu une entente de
la gauche et la droite notamment sur un
point que je trouve fondamentale sur le
communautarisme l'ump et le ps ont voté
la vente d'un terrain pour la
construction d'une mosquée un terrain
municipal sur monsieur ferrand
république il se trouve que c'est à
l'image de notre personnel politique
c'est à dire que c'est lamentable mais
aujourd'hui avec moi il n'y aura pas de
communautarisme en laye dans la ville
dense edouard ferrand donc avant avant
de passer à la suite de ce qu'on avait
prévu je pense qu'il est logique que
vous répondiez sur ce que vient de dire
edouard ferrand comme des petits -
francine weecksteen aussi parce qu'il
parlait d'un poil alors tout d'abord
monsieur ferrand franchement est-ce que
vous qui vous prétendez nous apprendre à
savoir comptez vous faites un amalgame
entre un budget municipal qui est de
l'ordre de 50 millions d'euros et vous
prétendez avec l'abaissement des
indemnités du maire budget
d'investissement compris si vous savez
bien comptés vous prétendez et vous
dites aux gens que baisser les
indemnités du maire et les adjoints
c'est ça qui va résoudre un problème de
l'ordre de 50 millions d'euros est ce
que vous laissez moi terminé s'il vous
plaît soyez au minimum poli est ce que
vous pensez réellement que les gens sont
assez bêtes pour croire des balivernes
populiste pareil ça c'est la première
chose et je m'arrêterai là dessus parce
que vous êtes dans l'outrance un tel
point que ça ne vaut même pas la peine
de voir la fin de mois la fin de mois
sens elle commence en début de mois et
je trouve inadmissible que le maire la
première chose son premier geste
municipal c'est d'augmenter ses
indemnités la démagogie c'est de la
démagogie la dernière fois c'est une
autre française ex
vous n'êtes pas souvent un sens donc
effectivement vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas bien le tissu commercial
ces données est en tout cas je sais que
pour fréquenter les commerces nous avons
réussi autour du marché couvert à faire
revenir des artisans et des artisans de
qualité qui font qu'ils sont très
contents d'être dans cette ville dit
travailler alors effectivement il ya
sûrement un problème de deux baux
commerciaux au sein de cette ville et
nous j'ai eu des propositions très
concret très concrètes par rapport à 7
ce problème des baux commerciaux et le
problème du commerce et j'ai
effectivement complexe à sens mais il
est nous avons la chance aujourd'hui
d'avoir un tissu commercial dynamique
avec des commerçants engagés dans leur
villa michel fourré une réponse et il
est nommé jusqu'au maire le commerce
commerce communautariste moi j'ai
entendu sur le communautarisme il faut
arrêter le terrain qui a été vendu a été
vendu suivant les lois de la république
ils construisent et vous allez vous
allez
monter régularité énorme
et donc la mosquée se construira sur ce
terrain je ne crois pas que ça
entraînera beaucoup de difficultés et
que tout ira bien et il n'y aura pas de
problème
pour le commerce le commerce je dois
dire c'est vrai francine l'a dit
le commerce commence à remonter au
centre ville on voit derrière le marché
couvert de nouvelles boutiques on voit
des choses qui s'installe le problème
principal c'est que je crois que il y
avait une des associations de
commerçants qui étaient plus ou moins
en bis biz et qu'il faudra évidemment
qu'ils se remettent ensemble
je pense que ça commence j'ai vu que le
président et président d'une association
s'est mis en retrait je pense que
bientôt les choses vont se faire et que
on va pouvoir enfin signé le fisac et
que les choses vont s'améliorer et on
qu'on va pouvoir travailler sur le
commerce de centre-ville je dois dire
que si au démarrage en 2008 j'avais les
bien l'impression que le commerce autour
du marché ou même dans la grande rue
était en train de tomber là j'ai
l'impression que les choses reprennent
de l'avant et que ça devrait marcher
sans problème c'est fermé produit avec
300 commerces axéens cornes commerces
fermés mais d'autres commerces qui
s'unira plus que des pompes funèbres
alors une réponse de
je suis surpris quand j'entends et puis
on est plus on avancera en autriche pour
les thèmes soulevés comme j'entends
monsieur ferrand parce que il est un peu
comme l'hirondelle vous savez ça revient
servi au moment du printemps est là il
revient à chaque fois qu'il ya des
élections municipales
aucun investissement au delà des aucune
opposition vous avez été
convoqué aujourd'hui vous êtes votre
mentor allait même pas là elle a jeté
l'épongé et vous se fait donner des
leçons de morale mais c'est ça comme si
j'en avais justement dans la vie
associative moi je pense que les gars
n'avaient sur la vie même pétion ville
un donc je je je trouve que ce genre de
propos est plus puisque plus que
critiquable alors en ce qui concerne la
mosquée
j'ai voté pour je pense qu'il faut avoir
un principe c'est qu'actuellement
effectivement comme bien le dire
monsieur ferrand c'est qu' il est temps
ce dossier est entre les mains de la
justice donc on ne se prononcent pas
tant que ce dossier est entre les mains
la justice je pense c'est pourtant la
justice un autre que moi tu fais le
recours à ce que vous vous avez
lâchement voter pour gilles qu'ils
méritent considération et concertation
c'est dommage parce qu'il me vous
perturbe un petit peu mais aperture d'un
petit peu non mais
edouard ferrand ferrand oui mais le
débat le débat et le brouhaha peuvent
parfois avoir
donc je propose qu'on essaie de
continuer à débattre mais qu'on évite le
brouhaha parce que sinon charleroi a du
mal aussi à développer ses arguments non
mais ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est que
et c'est très dommage ça c'est une autre
forme donc je voulais aussi paris n'est
pire comme il ya pascal de souza qui
nous attend gentiment pour intervenir
donc oui je voulais terminer sur le sur
le commerce et c'est vrai que
l'ensemble des réactions qu'ont et qui
ont été données c'est qu'il ya une
absolue nécessité de re travailler avec
toutes les a tous les acteurs ce qui est
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut reprocher
dans le dans le dernier mandat et en
particulier de monsieur pâris c'est
qu'en fait il n'y a pas eu de travail
avec la chambre de commerce ya pas eu de
travail avec la ccs il n'y a pas eu de
travail aussi dans la fédération des
commerçants on l'a vu ces derniers temps
où il ya une nouvelle association de
commerçants qui s'est mise en place et
j'ai dû et est obligé de faire un
courrier à monsieur le maire de façon à
ce que on arrête de la faire de la
politique autour autour des commerçants
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
après ces élections municipales il
faudra revenir un petit peu plus de
calme il faudra remettre tous les
acteurs autour du commerce autour de la
table de façon à faire en sorte que non
seulement le commerce du centre-ville
mais le commerce de l'ensemble des
quartiers de la ville se développe alors
je vous dis non mais je vous tiens au
courant publiquement de la situation
francine weecksteen et pascal cillon
sont en retard en temps de parole par
rapport à l'ensemble du plateau est ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on avance
on avait prévu de parler d'un certain
nombre de thèmes vous avez déjà abordé
le commerce oui mais bon je vous propose
de commencer le thème suivant pour qu'on
puisse avancer parce que sinon vous
comprendrez que on va rester un petit
peu scotché c'est le moment d'accueillir
pascal de souza ma consoeur de l'yonne
républicaine qui connaît parfaitement la
vie de sens forcément puisque c'est son
quotidien bonjour pascal merci d'avoir
attendu patiemment on s'était dit que
l'émission on s'était dit que dans les
thèmes importants il y avait bien sûr la
dimension budgétaire à samson c'est que
sans cette ville qui a eu des problèmes
budgétaires il ya longtemps déjà et puis
que c'est aussi là dessus que la
majorité a éclaté parce qu'alors quatre
d'entre vous étaient au conseil
municipal mardi soir il y a été question
des orientations budgétaires le vote du
budget lui a été remis après les
élections donc je voudrais vous demander
tout simplement quelles seront vos
priorités budgétaires pour 2014 après
une année quasiment blanche en terme
d'investissement serez vous plutôt
dépensier sachant qu'il ya des dépenses
indispensables comme la rénovation du
marché couvert
la réparation du campanile de l'hôtel de
ville la poursuite de la rénovation
urbaine ou pour suivre et vous la
politique de rigueur de ces dernières
années et je propose qu'on commence par
francine weecksteen qui était en retard
et pascal simon qui est en retard et que
tout le monde répondra effectivement sur
ces questions il y à des réponses
importantes à apporter à hausser nos nez
puisque ce sont eux qui qui nous
écoutent et qui nous regardent et la
réponse que je voudrais leur apporter
c'est qu'effectivement nous aurons une
politique d'investissement raisonnable
puisque les finances de la ville
permettront bien évidemment pas d'être
dépensiers à outrance est ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que nous nous engageons
sur une une politique fiscale beaucoup
plus raisonnable par rapport aux
habitants puisque nous n'aurons pas
d'augmentation de la fiscalité en ce qui
concerne sens pour les six prochaines
années puisqu'elle est déjà
effectivement importantes sur sur la
ville que nous devons effectivement
rénover le marché couvert si les
divisions que j'ai évoquées précédemment
on n'avait pas eu lieu les l'année
dernière nous vous seriez aujourd'hui
accueillis dans un marché couvert rénové
parce que nous avions un projet qui
répondait à la fois aux besoins des
habitants monsieur mon rôle rappeler que
et les commerçants nous n'avions pas
travaillé avec la chambre de commerce je
lui rappellerai simplement que nous
avons monté un dossier fisac et que ce
dossier fisac si nous n'avions pas
travaillé avec la chambre de commerce ni
la chambre de l'urgent est
illettrée bail il est très bien engagée
faut demander à l'adjointe au commerce
en place je ne suis plus adjointe au
commerce ou homère éventuellement en
tout cas mais ça qu'on va dire c'est de
l'argent pour développer le sondage est
en tout cas en tout cas ce dossier fisac
il a été monté le commerce pardon il a
été monté par par mois et par l'équipe
des par daniel paris ce qui était avec
déjà un certain temps aussi dans le
cadre de notre mandature non mais nous
nous avons nous avons continué à
travailler sur ce qui était le l'aspect
marché couvert jeune et j'ai toujours
aussi rendu à césar ce qui est à césar
ça n'est pas dans mes habitudes de faire
autrement voilà donc essentiellement
pour et effectivement nous aurons aussi
une gestion rigoureuse des charges de
fonctionnement puisque nous devons comme
dans un budget de ménage faire très
attention à ce que nous dépensons et
comment nous le dépensons pour être le
plus utile aux habitants et à sens
pascal simon vous étiez au conseil la
borne sur blue jays je voudrais quand
même dire une chose qui qu'il est bonne
de qu'il est bon de rappeler c'est que
le budget tel qu'il est actuellement et
qu'il va être laissées par la mandature
en place est meilleur que celui qu'elle
a trouvé en arrivant donc c'est une
chose on va pas refaire on va pas
refaire un historique sur les 12
dernières années mais on a eu des
errements
elle a été centrale à sens elle a
démarré très clairement en 2002 lorsque
madame fort d'un trait de plume à rayer
un projet d'implantation de supermarché
à l'époque c'était carrefour qui a coûté
de l'ordre de 20 millions d'euros à la
commune ce qui fait que il a fallu dans
la foulée augmenter les impôts de 40 %
qu'elle a ensuite essayé de diminuer par
petites tranches de 40% ce qui a mis les
finances de la ville en très très
mauvaise posture lorsque daniel paris
c'est arrivé et qui a conduit daniel
paris sa ré augmenter les impôts de 15 %
donc là la pression
oui la pression fiscale de sens est dû
essentiellement à cet événement qui a eu
lieu en 2002 ça un deuxième effet kiss
cool comme on peut dire puisque ça servi
voilà
ça a servi aussi à multiplier par deux
la surface de grandes surfaces en
périphérie de sens et de démolir
complètement l'activité de petits
commerces de centre ville d'où le fisac
maintenant je trouve ça quand même un
peu fort de café que les gens autour de
cette table qui représentent la majorité
de droite de 2002 à 2008 où celle de
2008 à nos jours se bat pour la mise en
place d'un sujet fisac ils ont l'un
parce que ils ont laissé implanté au
chant en zone sud et les autres parce
qu'il parle un petit renoncement ils
n'ont pas démonter ce projet qui était
dangereux pour la ville des mots lille
centre ville et il se glorifie
maintenant d'utiliser le fisac pour le
redynamiser donc ça c'est ça c'est le
premier sujet pour la partie purement
budgétaire on a maintenant des
investissements qui sont indispensables
marché couvert en étant le campanile en
est un autre on a aussi il faut pas se
le cacher la construction d'un
restaurant scolaire il est indispensable
de conduire 1 à 2 de construire un
restaurant scolaire les premières années
de mandature la capacité
d'investissement de la ville on va se
désendetter en moyenne 2 2 millions
d'euros par an on a pour l'instant grâce
à la gestion de père de famille des
dernières années une marge
d'autofinancement d'un million on peut
s'endetter de 2 à 3 millions d'euros par
an c'est seulement ça qu'on peut faire
c'est pas la peine de mentir on peut
garder une pression fiscale
stable et se contenter d'investir 2 à 3
millions d'euros par an ça veut dire que
les trois prochaines années de mandature
elles ne seront utilisées que pour les
investissements indispensables et
ensuite on répare les grands projets et
là il faudra faire de la démocratie
participative
ce qui a le plus manqué à madame fort et
un monsieur pâris
gérer en bon père de famille oui c'est à
bout oui voilà mais est ce que quand on
gère en bon père de famille on peut
aussi faire ce que vous avez dit en
ouverture c'est à dire faire de
l'attractivité pour une ville oui il
n'ya pas contradiction il ya un espèce
d'équilibré qu'il faut qu'il se se crée
entre
gérer en bon père de famille c'est à
dire arrêtez ne pas faire de pression
fiscale excessive je dois vous rappeler
quand même que pour l'instant on a au
dessus de la tête les un million six des
pompiers
dont on ne sait pas si c'est nous ou si
c'est la communauté de communes qui vont
payer et ça va poser un problème
et si on est obligé de payer les 1 1
million 6
je ne sais pas comment on fera mais on
sera bien obligé d'augmenter les impôts
nous pour l'instant nous espérons ne pas
augmenter les impôts d'avoir une
pression fiscale toujours égale le
problème principal est évidemment c'est
qu'il faut faire aussi des
investissements pour faire travailler
les entreprises le marché couvert tout
ce que vous avez dit on est on est
entièrement d'accord il faut absolument
essayer
de travailler et de faire des
investissements pour faire marcher les
entreprises mais il faut bien dire aussi
que il faut aussi qu'on reste dans les
limites du raisonnable et les limites du
raisonnable c'est pas de faire des
emprunts à tout va comme avait fait
daniel parisse dans sa dernière année de
mandat où il avait quand même augmenté
il est arrivé à 13 millions
d'investissements avec les bergers tout
le reste nous ou tressés pas c'est
presque
en tout cas en tout cas on était en
train de plomber la ville à nouveau
parce que moi je pense que les
successions droite gauche ont toujours
plombé la ville et je pense que c'est
les politiques des uns et la politique
des autres qui a fait que les choses se
sont se sont
désintégrées progressivement et qu'il
faudrait quand même que tout le monde
ait said d'avoir raison de revenus c'est
à dire essayer de travailler pour que
les sénonais ne soit pas compresser
fiscalement et qu'on puisse aussi faire
venir des entreprises travailler faire
travailler sur tous les jean edouard
ferrand vous avez patiemment attendu
votre tour vous en remercie vous avez
abordé ce dossier fiscal tout à l'heure
et on sait que c'est un dossier crucial
aujourd'hui pour tous les français le
ras-le-bol fiscale alors monsieur melet
à votre avis qu'est la catégorie sociale
professionnelle la plus heureuse à sens
je vous laisse répondre les banquiers
les banquiers aujourd'hui chaque fois
qu'ils voient le maire de sens il faut
ils ont ils font un grand sourire il
faut un grand sourire parce
qu'aujourd'hui la ville de sens
rembourse chaque année quatre millions
d'euros 2,2 d'emprunt sur la tête moi je
pense que les laisser donner aujourd'hui
ce que ce qu'ils veulent c'est du
personnel politique vertueux on n'en
peut plus ne veut plus de ces dépenses
et je crois que tout à l'heure je
parlais de la baisse des indemnités du
maire et de ses adjoints je pense
qu'aujourd'hui vous faire des coupes
sombres il faut sabrer tous les budgets
je crois que la ville de sens n'a pas
les moyens de vivre à crédit et en bout
de la ville de sens n'a pas les moyens
navals enrichir les banques il faut
qu'elle s'occupe décès dans des lycées
damien voudraient quand vous dites sabre
et tous les budgets ce que vous pouvez
donner des exemples de muret est ce
constat concernant l'école la santé ça
conviendrait quoi je viens en 2001 la
ville était pratiquement sous tutelle
préfectorale
aujourd'hui enfin l'année dernière a été
aussi pratiquement sous tutelle
préfectorale si ça n'en finit pas c'est
toujours les vieux fantômes qui hantent
cette ville de son don concrètement vous
ouvre maintenant d alors et dans quoi
vertu il faut que les gens puissent se
rendre compte que les finances publiques
c'est un métier que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut exceller et il faut faire en
sorte que les sénonais est une note sur
le foncier bâti foncier non bâti soit
taxe d'habitation sur la taxe foncière
note beaucoup moins beaucoup moins salée
concret alors s'il vous parler de budget
oui non non je vous demande janine
xemple vous avez droit de sabre dont
baic obèses par exemple de 25 de son
budget de communication
d'accord je suis myope par exemple qu'il
y ait un conseil de citoyens qui se
rassemblent justement pour voir quelles
c'est dans la porte aux associations
aujourd'hui la plupart arrivés
s'associent la suède ça permet pas de
sabre et non mais concrètement je
voudrais juste que vous nous disiez
parce que c'est sûr que si mais ce que
si les aides aux associations c'est très
important il faut remettre de l'ordre
partout aujourd'hui dans les tensions
inhérentes à nous dire précisément
l'enquêté officielle plus n'aurait guère
de communication là il doit arrêter
cette machine infernale entre 2000 et
2011 il augmentation de + 65 % des 1 x
sens hélas aujourd'hui vous dis oui il
faut faire des efforts n'ont laissé fort
c'est trop tard maintenant il faut
appliquer une politique très claire il
faut sabrer dans tous les budgets
simplement sur le commerce le commerce
faut ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement sens
ressemble à toutes ces villes l'aide de
région parisienne vous rentrez vous avez
les centres commerciaux le multiplexe et
salles de spectacles etc la ville de
sens notamment d'un fort en octroyant la
possibilité à l'état marché régional
offshore de s'installer à sens à vivre
à l'époque lorsque j'étais comme ces
municipal a voté contre l'implantation
d'un différend commercial jeunes avaient
voté toutes les grandes surfaces ont une
surdensité au nord comme au sud on
laisse très bien mon petit comme on
laisse répondre mais si l'offre vous
allez revenir et c'est pas en une fois
vous allez revenir voilà je suis là il
avec deux minutes parole sur wii il va
répondre débonnaire aujourd'hui qu'ils
se montrent ici à sens parce qu'on n'en
peut plus de voir ses hommes politiques
qui à force de promesses n'ont rien
réalisé sur la ville ça pourrait être
une conclusion pour le moment mais vous
reviendrez bien sûr charles est vraiment
je ferais déjà un petit commentaire
parce que monsieur monsieur ferrand a
cité certains chiffres qui manifeste sa
méconnaissance totale des finances de la
ville donc ça chez nous et ça serait
donné d'inquiétants inquiet traitement
fait mon nom mon traitement non monsieur
mais malheureusement que la heureusement
d'ailleurs car la même nom mais vous
avez dit qu'il s'est trompé de chiffres
quelques chiffres non remboursés à
hauteur de 3 millions d'euros chaque
année d'ailleurs on le voit il n'y avait
pas rio de oro jeudi quatre millions
d'euros
j'ai le chiffre officiel de la data
alors on pourra confronter nos chiffres
mais ça m'étonne pas que vous soyez pas
précis parce que surtout que notre
mandature tant que vous êtes couchée
devant le ps aujourd'hui c'est pareille
fête lors je moi finalement je suis
l'objet je
serais parfait change s'il vous plaît
alors ce ferrand est ce que vous pouvez
me dire sur quel bouton je dois appuyer
pour moi parce que je sais
c'est vraiment et non mais
c'était intéressant oui mais là
aujourd'hui non sharga mort pour revenir
effectivement et par le geste que la vie
ne peut se permettre des choses est ce
qu'elle doit réduire son budget alors
non il faut voir la situation exacte de
la ville c'est vrai que la situation de
la ville avec les les dotations de
l'état qui vont diminuer de façon
sérieuse en 2014 à nouveau puisque on va
perdre à peu près 300 mille euros on a
aussi des charges qui sont complètement
incompressibles aujourd'hui qui sont les
charges de personnel je dis
malheureusement monsieur simon si je
cite des chiffres de la mandature de
monsieur cordiaux je regarde la
mandature de monsieur o correio 1995 10
millions d'euros de frais de personnel
en 2001
17,6 millions d'euros de frais de
personnel donc et ça c'est pas moi c'est
la chambre régionale dynamique et moi
c'est toujours mieux face d'un célia et
s'il ya eu un jour un déséquilibre qui
s'est fait sur nos finances c'est qu'à
un moment il ya eu je dirais des dérives
malheureusement sur sur certains
certains mandats alors c'est vrai qu'on
a nous aussi je dirais quelque chose de
favorable au niveau de notre ville c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure que
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu
d'investissement l'année dernière donc à
partir du moment où vous remboursez
votre emprunt et que vous ne faites pas
de nouveaux plutôt votre/vos prat et
vous ne faites pas de nouvel emprunt
automatiquement vous avez un ordi tenant
qui diminue sein d'un endettement un peu
forcé mais là nous sommes avec un
endettement de 25 millions qui va
permettre manifestement à faire un
certain nombre d'investissements cetc
contre 1 c non mais vous vous êtes
trompés parce que si vous regardez le
dernier documentation d'orientation
budgétaire nous sommes à 25 millions ils
semblent ils semblent heureux pour la
tape ya consensus pour 25
donc autre chose qui est
je dirais qu'il est difficile pour notre
ville c'est effectivement ce niveau
d'imposition puisque quand on compare
avec les villes moyennes on a un delta
de l'ordre de 40% par rapport aux autres
villes sur les contributions directes
qui sont demandés aux habitants donc
c'est sûr et je le vois dans tous les
programmes à partir du moment où on est
tous commencent à donner un programme on
ne va pas augmenter les taux de la
fiscalité locale ce qui est ce qui est
tout à fait logique alors je pense que
là aujourd'hui la ville a beaucoup de
capacités à partir du moment où on va
restructurer sa gouvernance selon nous
avons manqué ces dernières années c'est
une véritable gouvernance au niveau de
la de la ville de sens on a on a
également une possibilité c'est de
d'utiliser ce que l'on appelle les plans
pluriannuels d'investissements
plutôt que de prévoir ce qui avait été
prévu en 2013 c'est à dire de faire
pratiquement 12 millions
d'investissements une seule année avec
huit millions et demi de d'emprunt ce
qui aurait mis la ville dans une
situation très difficile dont je pense
que on a des possibilités de
restructurer notre ville on a des
possibilités d'investir dans notre ville
il faudra effectivement voir clairement
vis-à-vis des dépenses de fonctionnement
de façon à arrêter certaine gabegie mais
aujourd'hui on a une capacité pour notre
vie alors je vous tiens au courant de
l'évolution de notre petite affaire
edouard ferrand jérôme rota en avançant
temps de parole sur on va dire sur le la
deuxième partie du débat français je
voulais donc sur la partie budgétaire
vous proposer de répondre éventuellement
à ce qui a été dit puis on passera la
suite après francine weecksteen sur la
partie budgétaire moi ce que je voudrais
en tout cas sur les chiffres parce que
je voulais utiliser beaucoup vous aviez
envie de répondre oui j'ai beaucoup
ticket parce que effectivement monsieur
ferrand qui nous disent avoir compté ne
sait manifestement pas compter et effet
la valse
besoins de notre pourparlers et battant
mais pour vous mais moi je vois la
lettre précise à moi je prouve
simplement que les ces données si on
n'est pas que j'ai posé la question dont
vous soyez polis je sens que je ne fais
pas d'attaqués personnelles monsieur je
remarque juste que les millions valse
rapidement et en tout cas ce que je
voudrais aussi rappeler c'est que le
désendettement de la ville a été
significatif sous notre mandat 30
millions de cinq jeux pour la période
2008-2012 3 millions cette année 2013
bien que vous l'avez souligné pascal
c'était dû à une année blanche en
investissement et je pense qu'une ville
ne peut pas se satisfaire d'avoir une
année blanche d'investissement parce
qu'une ville doit investir pour ce pur
pour ses habitants pour se structurer
pour rénover aussi cesser ces bâtiments
donc il ne faut pas se satisfaire de ce
désendettement 3 millions cette année et
ce que je voudrais aussi dire c'est que
nous n'avons pas augmenté les impôts
pendant quatre ans et je pense que bon
il faut aussi le souligner parce que ça
a été une maîtrise budgétaire qui a été
assez difficile à mettre en place que
les élus en charge des finances qui se
sont succédé ont réussi à faire
dominique lapôtre et marie paule
chappuit et je pense qu'il faut quand
même souligner que nous n'avons pas
augmenté les impôts pendant quatre ans
et je voudrais juste bon pour pour
résumer un petit peu ce que ce que nous
voulons faire au niveau du bon sens pour
pour notre ville c'est pour suivre ce
qui est engagée parce qu'il faut être
responsable et effectivement avoir là le
suivi des dossiers qui sont en cours
afin de ne pas tout remettre en cause et
jeter tout à la poubelle comme on a pu
le faire pour le marché couvert et
c'était bien dommage parce que l'étude
était était bouclé les démons bien fait
de venir s'installer au marché
exactement et d'autres d'autre part nous
ne nous réaliserons ce qui est
indispensable et je voudrais pas par
exemple soulignait le fait de lancer un
cabinet médical qui devra répondre à la
désertification des médecins à la
diminution du nombre de médecins sur
sens et tous les jours nous avons des
habitants qui nous disent ne plus
pouvoir se soigner correctement et ne
plus pouvoir être suivis correctement
nous irons nous y répondrons tout de
suite dès notre arrivée parce que nous y
avons travaillé depuis long de longs
mois il avait fait quoi jusque
maintenant
non mais vous avez plein de beaux
projets a l'impression que tout est
mieux qu avec vous tout a marché à
propos qu'est ce que j'ai fait à propos
de projet il nous reste il nous reste un
gros quart d'heure avant la interruption
2010 on avait envie avec pascal de
parler d'un autre sujet alors sur lequel
sens a fait l'actualité il ya un an et
pas forcément en bien pour les pour les
dirigeants de la ville c'est celui de la
sécurité on se souvient que manuel valls
était venu à auxerre qui l'avait il
s'était exprimé sur ce qui s'était passé
à 100 c'est qu'il ya un dossier dont on
parle beaucoup à sens c'est celui ces
deux les yeux des caméras de
surveillance la vidéoprotection a été un
autre sujet abordé au conseil municipal
le conseil qui a autorisé le maire à
enclencher la procédure de mise en place
de caméras de surveillance dans la ville
avez-vous la tension les uns les autres
de concrétiser ce projet alors on va
commencer par va commencer par michel
fouet
alors c'est pas tout à fait ça puisque
vous savez qu'avec les services se
mettaient bien de micros dans la version
de votre bouche voilà que la subvention
vous allez demander une subvention d'un
an on en est on en est au stade de
l'étude c'est à dire que avec les
services de police avec les services de
l'état avec la gendarmerie
avec
la préfecture nous avons donc étudié la
mise en place de caméras
pour l'instant nous avons fait une
proposition
la prochaine équipe
pourra démarrer les appels d'offres
pourra voir combien ça coûte pourra
aussi savoir le pourcentage de
subventions que donnera la préfecture à
ce sujet
il ya eu toujours on nous a t-il 50%
c'est un bon chiffre je ne suis pas sûr
que vu l'état
des finances justement de l'état on
n'arrivera sûrement pas à ce chiffre il
faudra que les gens donc choisi ce là
vous nous parlez vous nous parler
finances mais par lennon intérêt alors
l'intérêt et moi je joue pour l'instant
aux démarrages je n'étais je n'étais pas
tellement
pour la vidéo la protection
mais bon j'ai changé plus ou moins
d'avis parce que nous avons vu par
exemple de mettre des caméras autour du
cosmos à la piscine et tous que les
choses avaient beaucoup changé il y
avait beaucoup de vols tout s'est arrêté
là dernièrement on a vu qu'il y avait eu
un incendie sur une bouche de gaz si le
gymnase où ils étaient où était
installée la bouche de gaz en question
avait une caméra peut-être que les
choses ne seront pas fait et je pense
que c'est un système de prévention il
faut qu'il soit associé aussi à des
forces de police vous savez très bien
que les forces de police à samson
diminué assez considérablement nous
avons nous notre police municipale
qui reste qui est quand même assez
modeste mais qui travaille bien avec
donc les services et le commissariat
central nous avons d'ailleurs signé une
convention pour travailler encore mieux
mais je pense que la propre la
vidéoprotection ne sert qu à titre
préventif
mais c'est si vous êtes pour rien alors
la vidéoprotection c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet dont tout le monde parle déjà
pour le financement ce que j'aimerais
bien moi rappeler maintenant c'est que
les préfets nous pousse communes et
collectivités territoriales a investi en
vidéo une protection pour une simple
raison et une seule raison c'est la
baisse des effectifs de la police
nationale
je suis vraiment désolé monsieur moreau
parce que vous n'y êtes pour rien les 2
200 référé encore aux absents café
madame fort pendant sa mandature
législative pour éviter que trente
policiers nationaux qui le territoire se
connaît on en est à discuter de
vidéoprotection
exclusivement pour ça on est on est en
baisse d'effectifs alors globalement
beaucoup de villes beaucoup de villes y
passe y compris des villes qui étaient
contre et compris des villes de gauche
oui alors nous on n'a rien contre la
vidéoprotection alors je le dirai d'une
autre façon
une autre façon que michel fourré pour
les incivilités on l'a vu on l'a vu avec
brennus on l'a vu pour les installations
privées la vidéoprotection limites et
réduit des incivilités c'est parfait
c'est parfait maintenant le rôle le rôle
de la ville en matière de sécurité c'est
de la prévention c'est de la dissuasion
mais c'est pas de l'investigation et
c'est pas de la répression dire que si
on essaye de faire faire à des caméras
vidéo autre chose que ce pour quoi elles
sont faites ça va absolument pas marché
ça déplace les pointes délinquance mais
de toute façon c'est pas dans notre rôle
de faire de l'investigation donc les
caméras l'investigation c'est pas pour
nous maintenant ça coûte cher là l'état
finance le raccordement mais ne finance
pas l'exploitation et ne finance pas
l'investissement je pense que la voie
qui serait raisonnable de dire aux
services de l'état s'est dit ok pourquoi
pas reporté une fois encore une dépense
sur les collectivités territoriales mais
il faut qu'il ait une contrepartie une
contrepartie intéressante ce serait
peut-être de dire cinq caméras un
policier voilà donnez nous un policier
national et nous on vous donne cinq
caméras c'est probablement pas ce qui va
se passer a pas probablement pas
maintenant ça nous interdira pas
d'installer la vidéoprotection de façon
raisonnable et raisonné à sens sur des
points absolument précis je pense que le
cosmos et quelque chose où ça on tourne
à prouver que ça marchait pour réduire
les incivilités maintenant si on met
tout notre argent dans la vidéo
protection est con dès qu'on délaisse
les deux parties qui sont vraiment
intéressantes pour nos qui sont la
prévention et la dissuasion et la police
municipale de sens elle n'est pas
modeste elle est juste un petit peu
éloigné de la population rapprochons le
commissariat et le poste de police en
centre-ville faisons en sorte que nos
policiers municipaux soient plus pour
contact de la population et puisse plus
jouer on va pas dire îlotage ça fait
vieillot un rôle de police de proximité
et surtout rétablissons la prévention
dans nos quartiers un médiateur un
policier municipal peuvent faire le même
métier voilà sur la même rue
les policiers sont ils partis de sens
sous la mandature de marie louise fort
et quel est votre avis sur la
vidéoprotection alors quand j'écoute ce
qui a été dit là je pense qu'en 2008 en
fait sens et est considérée comme une
ville pilote
avec sa police municipale et afek aussi
essentielle spdc ans et des poussières
spdc le comité local de sécurité et de
prévention de la délinquance pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas les accros là
donc c'est vrai qu'on en provence
procède souvent avec des appellations
met donc et on fait ce que ce que l'on a
vécu depuis le début de la mandature de
monsieur paris c'est un petit peu
d'angélisme beaucoup de dogmatisme
l'angélisme bas ça a conduit en fait à
réduire assez sensiblement le nombre de
policiers municipaux à changer leurs
horaires avant ils travaillaient 7 jours
sur 7 24 heures sur 24 là on les a même
éloigné puisque on l'est on l'est on les
a mis dans un autre dans d'autres
bâtiments et puis le dogmatisme n'a été
aussi de se prononcer bien que monsieur
pâris effet une étude spécifique sur la
sur la sur la vidéoprotection ça a été
de se prononcer en fait contre les
résultats de cette étude qui qui
prouvaient quand même qu' il y avait un
intérêt alors moi je nous pensons que la
vidéoprotection la vidéoprotection oui
exactement et je vais même aller plus
loin parce que nous avons eu énormément
de difficultés à l'époque pour avoir les
résultats de cette étude il a fallu que
l'on se fendre d'un courrier au maire
pourrait effectivement avoir les
résultats de cette étude alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que cette vidéo
protection mais c'est de cette vidéo
cette vidéo
je
vous explique non non non à la même
heure où il a mis en cause l'équipe
précédente et donc je pense que francine
weecksteen répondre et puis on reviendra
vers vous et bien c'est à vous après
alors je réponds sur deux points
effectivement en 2008 ce ceux qui ont
voté aujourd'hui
la délibération sur la vidéoprotection
ce sont ceux qui se sont opposés à la
mise en place de cette vidéo protection
dans en 2008 lorsque nous avions fait
effectivement cette étude la vidéo
protection comme d'autres l'ont rappelé
effectivement elle doit être mise en
place de manière raisonnée avec une
utilisation intelligente des caméras
avec effectivement le la nécessité de
voir quels sont les impacts financiers
les impacts techniques il faut tout à
l'heure on a parlé de fibre optique on
ne peut pas traiter des images si on n'a
pas d'une manière rationnelle de les
traiter et technique et puis je pense
qu'il faut aussi aborder un autre
problème dans ce traitement de la
sécurité de la vidéoprotection c'est
l'aspect intercommunale parce que la
délinquance ne s'arrête pas aux panneaux
de sens et que bon effectivement si on
n'a pas une cette réflexion
intercommunale de dire si on installe
des caméras c'est peut-être anin et
chant intercommunal pour que
effectivement on traite la délinquance
de manière communautaire et que l'on
voit enfin pour on est enfin une pour la
première fois à compléter à faire sa
déchetterie communale puis me permettre
non c'est très compliqué mais ça peut
être efficace plus efficace que de
mettre des caméras dans une ville
c'était efficace en termes de sécurité
mais politiquement très compliqué c'est
ça que je voulais dire non je pense que
c'est pas pour en avoir discuté avec des
maires actuels de l'intercommunalité
c'est pas du tout impossible à mettre en
place si on n'est pas dans la division
et si on est plutôt dans la
mutualisation des énergies au service
des habitants
messieurs ferrand donnez nous de votre
avis sur la vidéoprotection
écoutez la vidéoprotection pour moi ces
larmes des bobos il s'imagine comme
étant des caméras ça va arrêter la
délinquance alors ça me fait bien rire
parce qu'aujourd'hui les délinquants ils
ont des capuches et des casquettes et
c'est pas la vidéo-surveillance qui va
les arrêter alors sans ce n'est pas
chicago mais presque souvenez vous il ya
un an il ya un an y avait quand même
trois compagnies de crs dans le quartier
des champs plaisants même la bac
d'océane aurait pu à maîtriser la
délinquance sens malheureusement subi
une image de marque défavorable en
termes d'insécurité et c'est un réel
problème alors on nous parle de
vidéosurveillance les gens sont
convertis de surveillance ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent pour pas beaucoup
d'effet et laissez-les sur les plus
grands spécialistes qui le disent moi je
pense qu'il ya un vrai mesure la vraie
mesure c'est de renforcer le poste de
police nationale et de gendarmerie bien
évidemment la loi de 2009 de
regroupement police gendarmerie de
sarkozy a supprimé 10 mille postes de
gendarmes en france et 15 mille postes
de policiers en france malheureusement
la police municipale à sens a subi les
mêmes effets aujourd'hui il ya aux
policiers municipaux sur le terrain
avant 1 h 26 et il ya cet argent vers
verbalisateur est ce que vous croyez
vraiment qu'on a besoin d' agents
verbalisateurs avec déjà tout ce que les
impôts tout ce que les sénonais paye
comme un pot moi je pense que ce qui est
pas normal sur cette ville c'est que un
le poste de police municipale soit
excentré il faut une heure et demie tous
les jours pour la police municipale pour
venir à pied et pourquoi pour venir à
pied monsieur melet madame de souza
parce que il n'y a pas assez de voiture
il ya 18 postes de policier municipal à
sens et il ya un fourgon et une voiture
les autres sont en panne médiation et
voilà c'est ridicule il faut accroître
les moyens de la polynésie va notamment
fait en sorte que ce soit pas 9h30 19h30
mais qui a aussi des équipes de nuit
armés de police municipale qui
patrouillent dans la ville je crois que
vous marchent la tête à l'envers sur
cette ville de sens on n'a pas encore vu
qu'il ya un quartier qui pause 6 3 mais
non monsieur quartier qui pose problème
il faut absolument l'investir pour
rétablir la sécurité comment on a vu que
la première c'est bien de liberté on
avait une question aussi j'avais proposé
pascal daniel tarrisse l'ancien maire
avait justement demandé à manuel valls
quand il est venu dans le département
que la ville de sens soient qualifiées
de zones de sécurité prioritaire pour
bénéficier de d'effectifs policiers
supplémentaires je voulais votre avis
sur la question michel fouet
d'abord il ne l'a jamais vu au ministère
deuxièmement comme il arrivait avec un
bilan où normalement
la délinquance avait diminué
automatiquement le mini le ministre lui
a dit pas c'est peut-être pas la peine
d'avoir une idée de ce fait une donc les
choses se sont arrêtées complètement
parce que mes de votre point de vue est
ce qu'ils aient d'espèces sur une bonne
idée dans un quartier ce sens je ne
pense pas non je pense que les choses
doivent être reprises à la base mois les
caméras
s'est passé paul quelque chose de
primordial pour moi je crois qu'il ya
évidemment et une recherche de dialogue
avec tous les quartiers vous avez parlé
qu'on a diminué progressivement tous les
animateurs de quartier mais c'est l'état
qui nous a complètement liquidé de ce
côté là
comme me fait d'ailleurs pour un peu
tout maintenant on a plus que deux
animateurs au lieu de quatre je pense
que c'est c'est pas c'est pas tout à
fait normal
la police municipale elle essaye de
jouer son rôle de prévention
c'est vrai que là des problèmes de
voiture mais enfin il en a pulvérisé pas
mal donc faut dire
les choses vont peut-être s'améliorer ça
restera dans les perles de nos émissions
mais je pense que il faut absolument
relancer le dialogue dans les quartiers
et surtout aussi améliorer les logements
et les quartiers en eux mêmes vous savez
très bien que quand quelqu'un de la zup
veut aller à 106,10 je descends un sens
il considère la zup n'est pas considéré
comme étant à 100 se trouve ça
absolument anormal et tous les quartiers
isolés font que progressivement les gens
restent dans ce quartier et ne sortent
plus pascal simon zsp ou pas nsp bras
moi je vais je vais rien rajouté ce que
vient dire à michel à propos de la cgsp
je pense que monsieur ferrand il
s'assoit qui vient pas souvent à sens un
parce que il vient une fois par an donc
effectivement il y le journal puis je le
soutiens attendait ce match et
je crois que vous êtes incompétent
single mr d'ailleurs vous êtes tous nous
appeler tous soir au prénom mais bien
j'ai connu quand on aime on évite les
vaches et les mascottes au visage mais
auquel a commencé sur les cinq dernières
années chaque numéro la différence entre
nous et vous rendez nous les tissus pu
tout à l'heure alors essayer votre
projet y'en a pas aller vite alors
qu'ils nous étaient à l'origine alors il
nous reste une bien de 30 avant la fin
de cet agent les a terminées
en ont marre et je crois qu'ils ont
compris aujourd'hui à qui ils ont
affaire s'il vous plaît oui tu es pas de
quasiment alors bon hormis or hormis
hormis ce fait je pense que la z sp
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
forcément d'actualité il faut arrêter de
jouer sur la peur des gens il faut
vraiment arrêter de jouer sur la peur
des gens on a
s'il vous plaît on
va les chercher on va parler peut
glisser dans les quartiers bourgeois là
vous êtes bien sûr nous pourrons
présenter françois hollande françois
hollande c'est quoi ici là
socialisme ne criez pas edouard ferrand
ça résoudrait bien tiens monsieur
ferrand pendant qu'on parle de ça et
shanghai langage des gens qui regardent
aller sur la page de votre premier
adjoint madame ansa sur sa page facebook
pour voir un petit peu la photo qu'elle
a mis en page facebook on va voir ce que
c'est que la sécurité à la mode front
national à la marée noire précise est ce
que vous dites dans ce cadre si tu c'est
un monsieur qui a une cagoule de
terroristes et qui brandit si je me
trompe pas un fusil d'assaut m16 en
train de protéger sa voiture donc si
c'est ça l'image de la sécurité vous
voulez donner monsieur ferrand je pense
qu'on est effectivement pas d'accord en
effectivement pas d'accord et s'il y
avait plus de gens comme madame mansart
je pense qu'on aurait besoin de ce
montant là françois hollande avec son
casque lorsqu'il va avoir sa maîtresse
mais vous avez raison de son sujet c'est
du même niveau monsieur armand déa pour
faire la politique ces gens là on
s'éloigne on s'éloigne un petit peu
différent il aurait là donc pâti des
dinos reste 30 secondes dérision leur
parti est ce que je passe la parole à
francine parce que je pense qu'il nous
reste 20 secondes l'idée était de donner
aux os et donner envie de voter c'est
vrai qu'en bon je suis pas sûr qu'on va
y arriver mais bon en tout cas ce qui
moi pour la par rapport à la d'espèce je
ne vais pas revenir sur ce qui a été dit
juste doit bouger plus non mais je dois
vous coupez sérieusement il nous reste
cinq secondes on va être pompée
jetez-vous qu'ils recommenceraient tout
à l'heure on se retrouve